en cette période d'hiver les chansons nu
mais celui qui les labours continue de
travailler l'orge à sa manière le maître
le malt et ma production en fait c'est
ma production d'orge qui est transformé
en malt en plus de son activité
d'agriculteur emmanuel du fer fait
transformer 50 tonnes de son orge en
malt pour fabriquer de la bière une
envie de brasser qui lui est venue
presque par hasard
mes enfants m'ont offert un kit à noël
il ya 2 il ya deux ans trois ans même et
j'ai commencé comme ça une fois ou deux
puis après j'ai dit
j'avais envie de me diversifier aussi au
niveau de l'exploitation de sortir un
produit fini par rapport à la production
après une formation il crée alors ses
bières bonneval et dont il nous détaille
la fabrication après avoir mélangé l'eau
au malt à 63 degrés pendant une heure
ils filtrent la mixture et y ajoute ses
houblon qu'il laisse à nouveau cuir un
véritable travail de cuisinier et de
chimistes ça va cuire à peu près une
heure et pendant sept heures les
houblons vont libérer leur leurs acides
alpha ce qui va donner
l'amertume à la bière dernière étape du
jour transvaser la bière et y mettre ses
levure puis laisser fermenter pendant
une quinzaine de jours avant de la
goûter elle est conforme à ce que
j'attends en l'occurrence ici une bière
rousse légère fabriqué avec un malt qui
vient essentiellement de ses terres il y
mélange aussi d'autres produits locaux
on essaye même de rajouter sur certaines
zones vierges je prends des produits
d'autres producteurs tarderait joueurs
de l'épeautre des choses comme ça de la
coriandre
mais c'est 2 voilà de travailler
vraiment avec le local en tout emmanuel
prépare 120 hectolitres par an une
petite production qui représente plus de
15% de son chiffre d'affaires et apporte
beaucoup de satisfaction pour pas trop
ce rap et qu'en même temps on n'a pas
trop le droit à l'erreur mais c'est
vraiment un autre monde
c'est un autre monde de rencontrer les
consommateurs par rapport au métier
d'agriculteur surtout céréaliers
emmanuel encore beaucoup de projets il
compte notamment ouvrir sa boutique
d'ici début mars